so
members take your seats
after two years
just shy of a few days
we are back
[Applause]
we're going to go over a few things
first paul's going to go over a few
things
and then we're actually going to get
into
a discussion and
there will be some people doing things
they shouldn't do
so that you'll know you shouldn't do
them
but
it's it's this is kind of like a dry run
for a number of reasons making sure i
mean they've tested the machines and
making sure all the machines and
everything work the voting machines and
paul will explain about everything else
thank you mr speaker
first off welcome back to your chamber
the
purpose of today
for for especially for many of our
new members this is your first time
being in representatives hall in this
kind of setting so really what we wanted
to do
is sort of have a discussion about
decorum in the chamber
talk about
some procedural things and that sort of
thing
a few housekeeping things so first off
welcome to those that are tuning in
online via our our streaming video a
couple points i want to make just for
those that are watching online but also
for you here if you desire to watch
later on
we're testing some different angles so
you might notice that during the course
of this there's going to be some
close-ups and there's going to be some
far
some far back shots and it's because
we're trying to figure out the best way
to to stream i will say
that um this is the first time that
we're going to see cameras and and the
the definition of the cameras in this
chamber the way they are and it's uh
it's pretty it's pretty amazing so
um i i hope you uh
enjoy what you're going to see um that
being said uh if if any of our members
are watching
you have my cell phone number and if
you'd like to text me and ask questions
please do we will address those in the
course of the day
i've given my number out so many times
over social media and
in streaming service i i feel like i've
done it enough i just don't want to do
it anymore
so a couple couple things first off um
when you're in the chamber and i hope
you're all in your correct seats
the first thing you do is you push your
white button and you turn your voting
stations on
and what you can't see is that
from from our
standpoint
your seats that are black when they're
off are turning on to a yellow color so
that we know you're here
now this helps us
and and we can determine um especially
during voting if you're not in your seat
i look down and i know and then i look
over to you and see you're not there so
i'm not going to call on you when the
voi when the vote ends this is a lot
different than the clicker system we've
been using because
i don't know where you were seated in
those ginormous places so i kind of had
to go by the alphabetical list this is a
seating chart with your actual seat
assigned and those things so
this is uh this is helpful for a myriad
of reasons
when we begin the session day
uh the speaker
usually starts by banging the gavel and
saying members please take your seat the
sergeant-at-arms will encourage members
to take their seats and we begin from
there the
the thing to remember is that once we
start going in terms of uh our official
opening with the prayer pledge and
anthem the doors are closed and the
sergeants stayed
at the doors and you don't leave or come
in during that time because it is it's
sort of a quiet time in the chamber
after we go through those three things
then
members can come in
and go as they please
so that is just a a point for for
clarification
um
any questions on those things so far
good
this
is a very big gavel
and when it gets swung down especially
when the speaker is banging it that
means
it means that uh the speaker is bringing
the room to order and by bringing the
room to order that means all of you need
to come to order
when the speaker bangs the gavel because
it's noisy in here
as we've we've seen numerous times at
our off-site sessions it's because it's
too noisy and the members who are
speaking at these two
parts of the well
are entitled to do so and and we all owe
our attention to them
um if
and again this is a smaller room if
you're sitting up in the corner or
you're standing in the back
the acoustics in this room are such that
everything comes right back down to here
so the speaker hears it
and it and
every speaker i've ever worked for uh
hears it and and gets angry at the beams
so please just remember remember that uh
if dartmouth arms comes to you and asks
you to take your conversation out in the
hallway it's a pretty good idea to do
that
um we do have if you didn't get handouts
there are some handouts up front i just
want to go over those real quick the
first one is an evacuation plan or an
emergency exit type situation it has
where you're seated in the chamber
please exit one of those
exit ways if we are going through
whether there's a fire emergency or or
something along those lines that's
that's how we should exit the chamber so
please pay attention to that
the other form
is one of my favorite forms and it says
parliamentary inquiry at the top of it
and
it kind of gives you a brief outline of
of a parliamentary inquiry and and how
it should be done
i would just notice uh as well
when we were in our last session day we
had several very long parliamentary
inquiries and then representative weber
gave a
one of the best parliamentary inquiries
i've heard in a while and and i would
just mention i don't even remember what
the topic was but it was two sentences
it was it was to the point it it said
exactly what it needed to be said and
she went and sat down and that is a
purpose of a parliamentary inquiry it is
not
to have a further debate on the bill
parliamentary and i and i think back
just to 20 years ago when i first got
here as a as a kid
the
the parliamentary inquiries were usually
done by committee chairs
ranking members
leadership team folks they would get up
they would make their two points and
they would sit down and most of the time
it was because members who hadn't been
in the chamber were coming back in and
they were sort of getting their
their their information
as a quick
you know
memory uh bouncer so uh just a a quick
point on parliamentary inquiries because
we've we've very we've gone on very long
on those things lately and i think we
need to to cull it back um the other
form i have for you here is called
paul's parliamentary points and i'm a
fan of alliteration if you couldn't tell
these are all points from either house
rules from the constitution or for
mason's manual and as well as a few
points of our own custom usage and
precedent
and
you don't need to look at them now but
they're they're just some
some of the reminders about how we
behave on the floor specifically not
referring to people by name
you know
representative notter would not stand up
here and say hi lori um because that's
that's not appropriate uh apologies
representative stanford um so so that th
they're just points like that for for
your uh edification and also um just for
you know we we want to encourage a good
decorous behavior on the floor
a couple of other points that that we've
we've encountered a lot over the past
couple of years that that the speaker
asked me to sort of cover
we do not have a dress code in the new
hampshire house of representatives we've
not really needed to necessarily
everybody i think has a
a fairly fundamental understanding of of
sort of a business type dress for when
you are on the floor especially of the
house
but i always like to to say
please
dress in a manner that is respectful of
the fact that you are sitting in the
same room as a member 200 years ago
you're sitting
as a representative for a legislative
body that has existed since the 1680s
so so that's why i i that's how i've
always encouraged people in in terms of
their dress on the floor um so
we'll we'll leave it at that um
i think i think those are some of the
points that that the speaker and i kind
of briefly touched on
but we
we do have a brief um mock session we're
going to go through uh but
this is also an opportunity uh to talk
about
questions that you might have about
being in here
some some little nitpicky things for
example
you can't eat food in here folks
this is a no food zone
so if you have food
you really shouldn't do it in the
anterooms but if you have food
my good i saw my good friend
representative wilhelm over here
a couple years ago when representative
wilhelm was was a freshman
member he he came in with a very large
box of cheez-its now he is a young dad
like myself and and we we have to have
cheez-its in in supply at our homes all
the time
um so but i reminded him uh when when he
posted his picture on twitter that uh he
should probably leave those in his
mailbox in the back and he he
graciously complied
so just just little things like that
water is is acceptable in this room as a
matter of fact in a couple of months
when it's pretty warm in here there will
be coolers that will be set up in the
back
with multiple bottles of water so that
you can remain hydrated because
your safety is our concern especially as
as many of you recall in our last
session day
the safety of our members is paramount
we do have medical people on site
to
assess situations and deal with
situations as needed we have had medical
issues in this room in the past
but we have
not just not just members of staff here
but we also have uh we have folks on our
sergeant-at-arms staff as well that that
our emts and and as well as additional
members as well
i mean there are many members that are
volunteer uh fire fighters and and emts
in their own communities and
will uh will certainly
encourage their assistance if need be
any questions so far
okay
mr speaker
i said this at our last session
and
i'll say it again when we meet next week
the decorum
in bedford
in manchester
was
probably close to despicable by
our members
and i'm not picking on one side or the
other side
the
amount of noise the amount of
conversations that were happening on
both sides of the aisle was absolutely
100 percent unacceptable
i thought it was going to break the
podium a couple times when i brought the
gavel down
but it only lasted for a couple of
minutes
let me make it clear that will not be
tolerated
in here
i know
back when we were over
to the unh ring
speaker shirtless had the same problem
and we've had the same problem now for
two years since our last session day
when we spent 19 hours in this chamber
on march 13th
so the
decorum
will be enforced
and we'll have some other
incidences that are going to be
perpetrated on purpose
to make sure that everybody understands
that you don't do that
and as far as the debate goes
we picked a subject matter
that
we hope you will get some enjoyment out
of it
but at the same time
realize how a debate should be run
so
with that i mean we're going to go right
through it
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes the member from
charlestown representative stephen smith
who moves the house adjourned from the
session of december 31st 1999
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
don't suppose nay the eyes have it in
the house is adjourned
then we will go
to a prayer by house clerk paul c smith
thank you mr speaker
and this is just a reminder this is
members will rise for the for the prayer
and
this is not a
you don't have to participate
similarly one other thing just before we
get too far into it in a moment when we
recognize guests for our for our newer
members
after we recognize the guests
you should stand and turn to the gallery
and applaud them and welcome them to the
house so thank you
divine creator of all we offer thanks
for bringing these members together to
enhance their experience and the best
calling ever known
we ask for your blessing on all members
unable to be with us today
remembering especially our good friend
the honorable renee cushing
in your name we pray amen
the chair now recognizes the member from
hudson representative greene who will
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
through the fire the united states from
america and do the republic for which it
stands one nation under god
indivisible
with justice for all
the house will attend
to request for leaves of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives cleaver gold mason milor
and pantalakis the day important
business representatives connors cody de
palma mullen o'hearn pickering and
southworth the day illness in the family
representative amanda bolden
house will attend to the introduction of
guests
mr speaker please welcome adam sandler
and steven tyler our pages for the day
so folks just real quick uh i i
apologize i should have mentioned that
before
on days that we have pages they're
seated down here and we announce them
first and uh please after we announce
the the pages please do give them a
courtesy of applause then sit because
then we're going to get into the guests
and i will just mention too that
sometimes after the guests and you seat
we will have additional special guests
as we do today
mr speaker please also welcome robert
frost guest of representative mcguire jd
salinger guest of representative stephen
smith general john stark guest of
representative weiler the honorable
franklin pierce former member from
hillsborough guest of the speaker they
are with us in the gallery today
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
mr speaker also please welcome our
special guest the honorable daniel
webster the 14th and 19th united states
secretary of state guest of the house he
is with us in the gallery today
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the
consent calendar
are there any bills to be removed there
being none representative osborne moves
at the consent calendar the relevant
amendments as printed in the day's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the consent
calendar is adopted
the house will now attend
to the regular calendar
the majority of the committee on
resources recreation development to
which was referred house bill nine
creating a commission to study the cream
filling in oreo cookies
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative
mcguire for the majority
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution that the bill be
found in expedia to legislate
representative steven smith from the
minority
the question is on the adoption of the
majority report of ought to pass
the member from charlestown is
represented is is recognized to speak
against the majority report
thank you mr speaker i mean first of all
this bill was only filed because of the
washington dc oreo lobby and the
sponsors deep ties and addiction to
double stuffs
you're out of
you're out of order please confine
yourself to the subject matter
sorry mr speaker sorry carol
second mistake
you do not refer
to a member by name
now you may continue thank you mr
speaker i apologize to the speaker of
the house and my good friend from epsom
for my lapse in judgment and it will not
happen again
so study study why would you study have
you even tried these things they're
delicious there is nothing to study
the member will suspend the member knows
that we do not use props of any form in
the new hampshire house
sorry do you want them
at any rate study so
what will happen when we create the
study commission you'll have a
commission they'll meet right we'll
probably live stream it what does that
mean commissions on tv what are they
talking about oreo cookies i'm against
corporate welfare there's no way we're
going to have state-sponsored oreo
commercials so
for me
for you and for the girl scouts please
vote against this bill
the house will be in order
another
point
that got out a little bit out of hand
while we're off site
is the house does not show emotion one
way or the other on any subject matter
no booing no yaying no clapping
no boo no no no
showing of emotion of any kind
chair recognizes
the member from epsom representative
mcguire to speak in favor of the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
as you know
my committee has never been in favor of
unnecessary study committees they're a
waste of our time however in this case
the bipartisan majority of the committee
agreed that this was a topic they could
really sink their teeth into
we all agreed that this deserved study
not just on the techniques
but also on the important issue of
dunking
because as you know the classic dunk is
milk
but that tends to be
discriminatory to our lactose intolerant
constituents and therefore we needed to
consider other options
red wine of course
but you know
do you use merlot
or hardy burgundy or what
i've heard that heard rumors of white
wine but that's just not the new
hampshire way
so
we have
all these questions and the reason for a
commission rather than just studying it
in our own committee is that we need
people from other committees who have
knowledge that we don't we need people
from commerce we need people from
environment and agriculture
since they deal with the
division of agriculture markets and food
and there are allegations that oreos are
in fact food
we also need to have people from the
committee on legislative administration
to deal with other allegations
of
un
undue influence due to court campaign
contributions from big cookie
that's an important issue throughout new
hampshire
and in order for fair and honest
elections we need to
study the issue and settle it once and
for all
thank you mr speaker
why does a member rise
does a member yield the questions
yes
the member may inquire
just just before you point your point
just so everybody knows especially for
the freshmen
when we were out of out of chamber
you asked from a microphone wherever you
were in the chamber wherever you were in
the uh complex
if you're going to ask a question
in the chamber you must come down
to the podium and ask the question
you can't ask it from your seat
member may continue
thank you mr speaker representative
would you believe that my favorite is
the samoas
thank you for the question i have no way
of knowing what your favorite is
thank you
the question being the majority
committee report of ought to pass
a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
that roll call was requested by
representative huff
uh
this will be a roll call vote the
question is on the majority report about
to pass on house bill nine the chair
recognizes
the member from charleston
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if you know as i know that this bill
creates a commission to study something
that we know doesn't need to be studied
because everybody already loves oreo
cookies
especially the double stuffed ones
and since i know that it doesn't matter
what's in the cream filling because it
tastes great and because study
commissions are a waste of time and we
have so many of them bogging down our
process and we all know they're a joke
anyway
state your point of order
mr speaker this is not a parliamentary
inquiry the member is making a speech
and is referring to things which should
not be referred to on the floor of the
house
the member is correct
the member will do a proper
parliamentary inquiry
i am so embarrassed
okay thanks mr speaker if you know as i
know
that we shouldn't study any
stage your point of order
reinquiry
these are interesting this time around
starting a parliamentary inquiry with
the words if you know as i know
is incorrect would the speaker kindly
instruct
the member on the appropriate way to
start a parliamentary inquiry
the proper
start of a parliamentary inquiry is if i
know
standing up here
i know nothing
oh this hurts okay
maybe that was a little bit of
exaggeration but
you do not you do not refer to what i
might know
it's what you know
i apologize mr speaker
if i know that we shouldn't study
anything else this year because we're up
to our eyeballs and work would i press
the red button to vote down this dumb
recommendation
not quite a proper ending representative
but
the chair recognizes representative
nunning wong for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that the filling
and oreo cookies should be studied so
that our constituents receive the
nutritional information they need to
serve their families a quality
cream-filled delight
and mr speaker if i know this is simply
a study commission that does not require
any changes to our laws would i then
press the green button to study this
important matter
thank you for a proper parliamentary
inquiry
this will be a roll call vote all right
are we ready to go
this will be a roll call vote
if you're in favor
of house bill 9
with the report of ought to pass you
will press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
this is a another point folks in in this
chamber once you hit the end of that 30
seconds you can't vote anymore
so if you haven't voted in that 30
seconds
i'm going to call your name
um i i understand now keep in mind a lot
of these buttons haven't been pushed in
a couple of years so there might be some
stickiness going on so in those cases i
will you know set your vote for you i
got you as representative
represent bernardi
i i understand
so just a thumbs when i when i call you
just give me a thumbs up or a thumbs
down
thank you
have all members president had a chance
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
14 voting a 27 voting nay
the motion on oreo cookies fails
for what purposes remember rise
state your motion
mr speaker i move in expedient to
legislate
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 9.
you want to try this do you want to do
you want to i was going to say do you
want to try this session
you want to try it again
all right a division has been requested
so
the motion before us is itl this is a
division vote
uh they're gonna they're resetting it
right now
trying to get all the kinks out of this
today so we don't have to worry about it
next week
for what purpose does a member rise
this motion on the floor
mr speaker i move to table the motion
i recall that motion mr speaker good
choice
this is a division vote
the motion before us is inexpediting to
legislate if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
harley
[Music]
thumbs up
just to clarify so if you don't vote in
that 30 seconds i'm going to call your
name
and you have to give me a thumbs up or
thumbs down because we're i'm going to
cast a vote for you if you are in the
chamber you have to vote
we don't abstain in the new hampshire
house
okay
i'm voting for you i voted on your
behalf because you didn't push your
button
that's why i need the thumbs up or the
thumbs down
no problem
so the question is if you're in the
middle of the 30 seconds can you change
your mind and switch by all means if you
can you can play if you want to and
shoot you know go back and forth i would
just be mindful at the end of that 30
seconds whatever
is is recorded as recorded
we have had members who have tried to
play beat the clock and wait until the
very last second and the buzzer gets
them and they didn't vote and so then i
have to call their name and people go
yes sir
so
representative stapleton asked if he
pushed the wrong button
and the bell goes off and the speaker
before the speaker has stated the voter
after the speaker has stated the vote
if if if you
uh if the speaker has not announced the
vote so if i'm checking with other
people
and because i see that that
okay i see a couple yellows on so that
means i'm looking around to see if if
they're
if they voted or not if you
need to get my attention and that brief
this is a very brief period so before
the speaker states the vote if you come
up very quickly
you shouldn't even leave your seat
you're not supposed to leave your seat
until the speaker states the vote um so
if you get my attention or whatever i
will change it but that that really
should not happen uh because once that
bell rings and you've you've voted that
that's
it's hard to unring bells
in terms of divisions
i would just be mindful that divisions
are not recorded the number is reported
but the the role the the vote is not
recorded so
you could ask for reconsideration if you
were on the prevailing side if you
needed to
if you
were not then you cannot move
reconsideration
i really don't advise that um i really
the onus i i i don't mean to be rude but
the onus is on you to to know how you're
voting um
you know once you you've when that bell
has rung i mean you really should
that should be it
um if not there is a mechanism for you
to note in the cl in the in the journal
that you voted incorrectly and you wish
to be recorded as having voted the other
way
that is a mechanism
that we put in the journal as a courtesy
to to members
so even if
even if for example
you had an emergency and needed to step
out in the hallway to take a phone call
and you did not vote but
you wish if you had you would have voted
this way i have a green sheet teresa
down here our journal clerk
the best journal clerk
if if you
she's got this little green slip and it
says that you either voted or you didn't
vote and you voted this way but you
meant to vote this way
and we'll put that in the journal
so
if if one of your constituents gets mad
at you you can call them up and just say
no no i meant to do this i was talking
with my neighbor not paying attention
one other point
we saw a lot of
moving around
in the
outside venues that we are at
people walking around and in that nature
when we're in this chamber
you will remain in your seats until
the end of the vote
and once i call the vote then you could
get up but everybody should remain
in their seats it isn't a
time to get up and start walking around
and talking until after the
you know i call a vote
um
yeah forgot this part have all members
in the chamber voted that were that were
eligible to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
30 voting yay 11 voting nay
the member does not walk in front
of the speaker's podium
i'm sorry mr speaker
may i be
acknowledged for uh unanimous consent
yes
i'd like to apologize to the house for
breaking the decorum my old seat last
term was 4-4 i was 4x4 then and i left a
pack of gum in my seat and i just
wondered if it was still there so i
apologize to the speaker and to the
house
that is one
one of the
instances that does happen occasionally
where somebody will walk in front of the
podium and in many cases it's a freshman
and that is an absolute no-no
so for all you freshmen that um
things were a little bit
convoluted in our other locations uh
where you had to come up to have your
clicker checked or something like that
uh that doesn't happen in the chamber
you do not walk in front of the uh
podium here you go up and around if you
have to come down or vice versa
there's no debate on this one
so i'm just going to read through it as
if so you'll know what a voice regular
voice vote is
committee on fight
finance to which was referred house bill
99 fnal
in heck making appropriations to the
department of food and agriculture to
promote extra milk production to go with
cookies
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution that
the bill be inexpedient to legislate
senator weiler for the committee
question before the house is the
adoption of the committee report of
inexpedient to legislate
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
i was truly unsure what the vote was
uh i i will tell you normally
in this chamber unlike our outside
venues
uh where it was very hard to determine
the the eyes and the nays
that one i really truly couldn't
determine it was about equal so
we'll test the system one more time and
have a division vote
if you're in favor this is the the the
motion before us is in expedient to
legislator and house bill 99 this is
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
just a very quick note there too for
those of you who saw representative
notter came in
in the middle of a vote and our
sergeant-at-arms just kicked her out so
once we're in the voting mode nobody in
nobody out
if all my president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
25 voting yay 12 voting nay
it honestly didn't sound like that
i mean that that's enough
yeah
yeah the
yeah the motion wasn't expedient to
legislate
got to get used to being back up here
myself
um
that's something that i i would um
recommend a lot of times when we do
voice votes
a lot of people don't vote
and it can get very convoluted sometimes
so i would strongly suggest that
when the question is put to you
you do express your opinion one way or
the other on a voice vote
but it's a lot easier to determine in
this chamber than it was outside it was
very difficult
because the room was so big on both over
in bedford and
uh at unh
uh and and uh manchester
um
we we had one more
but
again i
i don't think we need to get into one
more uh
debate
[Music]
we are now at the point
where the house will attend to
announcements
the chair recognizes the member from
charlestown representative stephen smith
for the third reading motion it should
be representative osborne
the question
i haven't got to do it from that here
before this is awesome hey resolve that
the house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only and resolutions by captions only
and that all bills ordered a third
reason be read a third time by this
resolution and that all titles of bills
be the same as adopted and that they be
passed at the present time and when the
house adjourns at b to meet wednesday
december 31st 1999 at 10 am
question is on the third routing motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
now the house will attend to
announcements
do you have any
jerry
jay recognizes the clerk thank you mr
speaker for those members who have not
been here in a while please make sure to
check your mailboxes and empty them on
your way home this afternoon thank you
the house will now attend to a request
for unanimous consent
and
chair recognizes representative stephen
smith for the purpose of an apology
[Laughter]
for all of them
yeah
so i i apologize to you mr speaker and
to the house for being the worst example
of a representative that i've seen in
quite some time
but you know
it matters reverence for the chamber
think of the people that have stood here
is a marker out front that says
general lafayette was welcomed in this
room in 1825 and when i first got here
in 2010 realizing that i thought
i try to need to be a better me when i'm
in this
room and be worthy of the chamber and i
just i hope all of you feel that too
and my sincerity in that and understand
how painful this exercise was for me
today
representative osborne moves at the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills enroll bill's
amendments enrolled bill's reports and
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those favors say aye
all supposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
the house is in recess until thursday
march 10
9 a.m
uh yeah we don't need that
so before before we leave what what we
tried to do today is especially for the
freshmen
is to
go over how
we do things in the chamber
and i know it's very similar as to what
we did outside
but there is quite a bit of difference
once you're sitting in here
than when we're in a
55 or 35 000 square foot room
decorum is is absolutely
necessary for us to get through our
business
and as i said earlier it will be
enforced
and
pis
will be enforced
no more novels no more books being read
no more discussions a pi is a pi
and
we saw
representative weber deliver a perfect
one
over in
manchester
a couple of weeks ago
that's what a proper pi is that's what
it was
they've gotten out of hand over the past
few years
and
we're going to go back to doing proper
pis
so what i'd like to do now is is
open it up to questions for anybody that
might have a question
for myself the clerk
majority leader the deputy speaker
um uh the clerk does have a couple of
quick more quick points to go over thank
you mr speaker we i did get a couple of
text messages um out during the during
the course of this as as we sort of
expected um
one thing certainly that that that has
has
been a a uh a constant sort of annoyance
for me is cell phones going off during
session
for those of you that know me i get a
lot of text messages i get a lot of
messages on my phone but i've got the
vibe the i've switched it off so that's
just the vibrate
if i it's in my pocket or if it's in my
shirt pocket i i'm going to feel it
but i don't disturb the session by
hearing
so please
silence your cell phones
during session
uh another thing um
political uh paraphernalia at the well
no fly no fly zone um we don't wear um
so i know that there are certain
elements that that that members
wear from time to time campaign pins
campaign buttons
what you have on your lapel you see here
i've got the little seal of new
hampshire
if you have a campaign pin like that
that it's never been something where
you're going to be crucified but if you
come up here wearing a
shirt
like this
that has a political
statement or a campaign
slogan or whatever
that's not acceptable in the well yellow
scarves
yellow scars are not acceptable for
speaking in the well
that is that has long been the policy
under both republican and democratic
administrations so
i just make make those points
hats
gentlemen do not wear hats in the
chamber
this also applies for when we're holding
committee hearings in here as well
and uh if we have folks that are coming
in and testifying they need to
understand that they are still
in representatives hall and those
those same customs apply
gentle ladies
do wear hats and
there is no prohibition on that
we do have a member
a male member who has
undergone
head surgery and and has permission of
the speaker to wear a hat
because of
exposure
so that is
in those situations
please see the speaker
we will accommodate those things
additional accommodations um from time
to time
members for whatever reason break their
legs around here like it's going out of
style
and what happens is
as you know in your seats it's sometimes
hard to get in get out and that sort of
thing
so what we will do if you coordinate
with myself the speaker's office we will
set up a chair
usually in the back of division one or
five for those members
where they can stretch out and spread
out and
i will just know to look for them during
each recorded vote so that i can record
their up or down during session so
please if if something like that happens
please let us know
i think that's all i have for you now mr
speaker
representative smith do you have
anything
so as you saw
representative notter i i would just
mention representative notter took one
for the team
um in in crossing the well earlier uh
she was was hijacked into doing that and
she was a little concerned because she
didn't want to be called out but she's
she's a trooper so thank you for that i
would just i would just mention um
that uh
our custom is
it's actually more than a custom it is
it is in masons that no one crosses in
front of the speaker during during the
session
you will often times see
during the beginning of the day or
coming back from lunch if
we're getting ready and we have some
members who are are moving a little slow
a little slowly uh the speaker might
step down
to the floor so that the member can do
so without without
avoiding the
the custom
okay i have another text message
sorry representative i'll be right there
uh
i had a question asked uh should they
push their white button to turn off
their seat if they're going to use the
restroom that helps us out it does help
us out so if if you do need to go use
the restroom
if you turn off your station that means
that i'm not looking for you
when the vote has concluded so that is
is helpful
if you are able to do that
if not
it we're not going to send out the
police don't worry representative weber
what's the policy on the isles because i
have seen it done both ways and i have
had to apologize for doing it myself
if i i in my first term
we were only ever allowed to use the
aisle between four and five and the
aisle between one and two
and in later terms
the two middle aisles have been used but
i know at least at one point i was
required to apologize for walking down
the aisle when somebody was standing
here and speaking i didn't cross in
front of the speaker but i
did certainly obstruct the podium
but i have also seen times when that has
not been called out so i just wondered
what the current policy was on the isles
thank you very much representative that
is a perfect question um when members
are speaking at the well
from either podium you should not
come down the aisle to either go
out this door or
to go to that corner while the member is
speaking because you are especially now
with our cameras where we are going to
be having more of a focused angle it is
um it is disrespectful to the member
that is speaking because you are cutting
off their speech if you are if you are
in the first row and need to go out that
way to use the facilities that's that's
a different story there you're going out
but to come down in front and cut off it
is it is disrespectful to the member
speaking um i have another one uh
from as a request for our
sergeant-at-arms teams um
we issue every one of you a security pin
and a name tag
granted some of you
received your name tag
30 years ago
so you might not have one anymore
but we do give out security pins at the
beginning of each session for our
sergeant-at-arms purposes uh for our our
our doorkeepers at the back and and
other folks if you could wear
an identifying
badge
name badge or your your pin
it does help in terms of identifying
and and trying to keep out other folks
especially while we were off site there
were frequent cases where
non-members were coming onto the floor
and in in some instances this actually
happened during session
and that is a
strict strict no-no
the only people that are allowed on the
floor are the members
staff and press but even press is
limited to where they're supposed to be
so please
it would be helpful to our team if if
you could do that
i'm sorry
this year's color was green
so if you should you should have a green
pin
if you don't
let's talk afterward
okay
i hope everybody got something out of
today
and
i hope that
next week is
as successful as today was
and that we
observe the proper decorum
and
if i'd asked
both the minority and the majority to
try and convey that to the members
during their caucuses and i'm
sure will be coming up
clerk's got one more thing sorry mr
speaker the the chief of staff who cares
greatly about you wants to make sure
that you've signed in to get your
mileage for today for being here so
please do sign in up in the speaker's
office after after the event's over so
that you can get your mileage for today
thank you
has anybody got any questions or
comments that they'd like to make
represent them not
just very simply
when you come to the well the first
thing you should do is adjust the mic so
that we don't have to hear this like oh
can't hear you oh how about now now can
you hear me now just get in the habit
get in the habit of pulling it right
down to your mouth the very first thing
yes
yeah at the end of the day yes
steve
got anything else
lucy you've got anything
i was reminded by the clerk
that i was just wrong it should have
been representative smith and
representative weber and i apologize to
the two members
see
mr speaker just another reminder if you
need to leave during the session day
normally when we were off-site i told
you to text me when you were leaving
when you're leaving if you could
please check out with me up here
because we will actually note the time
you're leaving and we can excuse your
votes going forward okay so please do
note note when you're when you're
leaving if you if you have to go quickly
and you don't have time to stop by and
see me you can stop by the speaker's
office and sign out at that time
as well we'll we'll coordinate but
when you're ready to go if you need to
go during the day if you want your votes
to show online as excused please uh
please do sign out so that we can excuse
those votes
the other thing too just as a reminder
especially for those watching at home if
you are not going to be in session
please call the clerk's office please
email the clerk's office
we are we are very friendly with our
friends in the two party offices however
sometimes in in the myriad of emails
that we get
between the the three offices we don't
always get that communication if
somebody's not going to be in session so
it is important that you call or email
the clerk's office so that we can excuse
you for the day as needed
i did have one other question about
bringing bags briefcases etc to your
seat
as you can tell
we we don't have desks here in new
hampshire
we don't have a ton of room beyond this
the spaces
here in the in the in the chamber in
your mailboxes in back um if you have a
briefcase uh if you have an assigned
locker
feel free to leave your briefcase there
uh but but uh certainly if you're
carrying an old-school barrister bag
you're not going to be able to
store it under your
seat in front of you or in the over
head bins above you so
um yes i
i will
there there was a question about lockers
um if you
come upstairs in and see us we will talk
about that and see if there are any
still available
going once twice
john
representative
i apologize again
and this is a question sort of i know
it's a little bit
off topic but it's an indirect question
a lot of us park in the store street
parking garage and i was there today and
i noticed there's been necessary
renovations and i know being on the
public works and highways committee i'm
very familiar with that issue
by next
thursday
i've noticed construction equipment in
some of the parking spaces is that
garage going to be totally ready for
members who park in that garage and
because i don't want anybody being late
for our first session
it is going to be as ready as we can
make it representative okay and another
question too are you is it going to be
security over there mate another thing
i've noticed seems like there's a lot of
extra cars that are not represented
sometimes when i've gone over
on days when i've had to come down here
will security be there make sure that
keep out non let on on the day that
we're sex because i think that's very
important because if all of us use our
cars
that those who i know some of us park in
the llb and on the street
that you're going to have you might have
a problem with not members not being
able to park in stores if that's their
assigned parking spot
uh yes
yes
and we're also i believe
we will have the shuttles
reinstituted like we had
two years ago okay thank you very much
appreciate that yeah we're working on
all of that
and we're also working on a new parking
garage
if there is nothing else
yes
in the speaker's office upstairs
yeah yeah there's there's a sheet up
there in the uh receptionist's
uh office that you can sign up for
mileage
um mr speaker i i just want to briefly
mention too
a lot of times as you can see this is a
working area down here um so you so you
all know my staff and if you don't i'm
going to reintroduce them to you
mike is our assistant clerk mike is
responsible for amending every piece of
legislation as as it's going along he
also um not just amends legislation but
any any time we we change uh if we adopt
something i mean there's there's a whole
bunch of things that need to happen he
dockets the bills etc so
that's what mike is doing primarily
during session paul is
our bill status and calendar clerk so
paul is running the voting system paul
is also doing the bill status so he is
updating those dockets that appear
online and while he's not doing that
he's working on getting the calendar
ready as well so uh he's he's definitely
busy um and he is as you can tell
there's a computer here he's operating
the voting system from the floor but he
also has a laptop down here um where he
will be um utilizing that for docketing
and working on the calendar and teresa
over here is our journal clerk and she
keeps track of everything she makes sure
that we're all honest
she makes sure that you're all honest
and
especially me
and she's also the person that
transcribes your debates so please
if you're going to make a motion to put
remarks in the permanent journal
if you have those remarks prepared ahead
of time please email them to us so that
it will save her a significant amount of
time and in in just copying and pasting
versus uh trying to figure out a word
now that being said i enjoy going into
teresa's office when she can't figure a
word out and we listen to it about 15
times and then between the two of us we
can figure it out
i i don't think there's ever been a word
we haven't figured out um but uh but it
again it it would it would help us in
the long run so
so we are working down here that being
said when you need to come up and talk
to us uh about something specific um if
if there's something specific that they
that you need from them
please just make sure that you know it
is what you need from them if it's
signing up on a bill or something along
those lines i've got all that stuff here
so come see me here
if uh if especially if the if the
democratic leadership team needs me over
here i will come down and often talk to
them there rather than making them come
all the way up over and around here
but again this is this is where i'm at
if you need bill stuff questions etc and
again you do know my uh that you are
able to text me
and email me here on the phone and i
will i will answer that
any other questions regarding that stuff
i think just just
one more thing
um
next thursday will be the first time
that we've been here as a party in two
years
and we've had a lot of
parking problems
if you do not have an assigned space
in the lob
or on the street
you must park in store street
thank you
thanks everybody for coming and
we'll see everybody
at least next week if not sooner
you